good morning believe nation today's
message is dreams without goals are just
dreams over to you Denzel Washington
dreams without goals are just dreams and
they ultimately fuel disappointment
goals on the road to achievement cannot
be achieved without discipline and
consistency I pray that you all put your
shoes way under the bed that night so
that you got to get on your knees in the
morning I love this message because you
need book you need to have the dreams
and you need to have the goals somebody
who has goals without dreams you're not
going to accomplish anything huge
because you can't think big and somebody
who has dreams without goals that just
end up living a life without actually
ever doing anything so you need to have
both dreams and goals I think a lot of
people who do have dreams are holding
themselves back by their limiting
personal beliefs if you tell yourself
and you can't do this because you don't
have the education or the money or the
experience or the network or the contact
of the friends or whatever it is right I
can't do this because of blank and
because you believe that so much to your
core you always have these dreams about
all you want to accomplish but you never
actually go out and do them I find that
a lot of people have a moment of
boldness you wake up at 2:00 in the
morning with this great idea and you
write it down and then the next day you
wake up and you look at that idea like
oh I can't do that what was I thinking
that's that's crazy and so the key thing
is 1 take action immediately right
whenever you get that moment of boldness
that period no matter how long it lasts
it makes you feel like you can break
free from where you are right now when
you feel like that and you have this big
dream you got to actually do something
right there on the spot take some action
make a phone call send an email
schedule a meeting whatever it is take
immediate action and the next step is
making sure that you spend time every
single day on your dream at least half
an hour every single day to make forward
progress no excuses every day schedule
it in make it a priority so the question
the day for you guys today is what's
holding you back from taking action on
your big dreams leave it in the comments
below I'm gonna join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso